là où ça bouge nous sommes à vire
normandie pour un concours de jeunes
talents
on vous dit tout il faut s'inscrire
jusqu'au 18 janvier donc quels sont les
critères isabelle les critères sont vous
devez être âgé de 12 à 30 ans et avoir
un lien avec la normandie soit être né
en normandie travailler en normandie où
habitait en normandie où est-ce qu'on
peut s'inscrire vous pouvez vous
inscrire en ligne sur le site du
concours des jeunes talents en
téléchargeant la brochure d'inscription
la philosophie jean claude de ceux de ce
concours
la philosophie de ce concours c'est de
se dire que tous ces jeunes talents de
musique classique ont besoin d'être
aidés ils ont besoin d'être aidés
pourquoi parce qu'un bon nombre d'entre
eux n'aura jamais la chance de pouvoir
se confronter au public est là
s'ils sont qualifiés et bien ils auront
cette chance tout à fait extraordinaire
c'est merveilleux pour eux et ça
s'adresse à tout le monde
si ce sont des chanteurs et des
chanteuses c'est bon si ce sont des
instrumentistes c'est bon donc allez-y
inscrivez vous vous avez jusqu'au 18
janvier 2016 avec les eaux du groupe
désire on va apprendre à faire un slide
guitare s l ide
alors un seul est c'est joli deux notes
et je reste le doigt appuyé sur la corde
pour comme ça pas raison et dans un
accord ça donne
et si je le faisais pas ça donnerait
slide comme glisser entre deux notes
c'est pour faire plus joli c'est
pourquoi cela a été je pense pour lier
les notes
oh
on
là où ça bouge nous sommes à corde
devant la salle le sillon de la mjc de
chemin vert pour vous faire découvrir la
culture congolaise et pour ce faire on a
rendez vous avec le chorégraphe et mais
qui foula qui dirige la compagnie bang
bang
oh
la compagnie de danse manguy bantous
fête ses 20 ans
pendant une semaine des rencontres des
débats des cours de danse conte animé la
mjc du chemin vert mais aujourd'hui ces
répétitions là aujourd'hui on travaille
pour le spectacle de demain qui
s'appelle luhaka ça et ensuite on
travaillera pour le spectacle de samedi
puisque voilà on essaie de faire des
choses par étapes
alors justement de quoi il est question
dans ce spectacle alors dans nos
spectacles waka ça veut dire déjà faire
entendre faire entendre alors le projet
s'est construit autour de pierrick donc
il m'a demandé de venir travailler sur
sur un argument qu'il avait mis en place
et en fait l'argumentaire c'est voilà il
a sillonné le monde un peu partout avec
l'ong omar donc ces longues au maquis un
peu la vedette
voilà les bretons hambourg qui sont des
tambours vraiment pour nous c'est
l'ancêtre même qui parle dans ce tambour
parle alors c'est hambourg ayant voyagé
partout et lui et a accumulé plein
d'autres choses
qu'est ce qu'il en a fait de cette
culture ancestrale et les gens ils
connaissent pas assez ce qu'on a à dire
et nous nous côtoyons tous les jours
est ce l'occasion de venir savoir qui on
n'est pas ce qu'on va leur présenter
vraiment le fond de ce que nous sommes
là notre intérieur voilà qu'il vient de
rencontrer pour que demain ils puissent
enchaîner dans les meilleures conditions
ça veut dire que la culture c'est très
important ça c'est de te connaître
l'autre a bien sûr moi ça fait 20 ans
que je suis là et les amis ça fait
quelques années aussi la première chose
qu'on a faite c'est de découvrir la
culture du pays d'où l'autre qui nous
accueillait sinon c'était pas possible
il remercia manqué et inversement quand
on a envie aussi de partager de dire
aussi barguna d'où on vient c'est ça
voilà c'est justice a expliqué et c'est
net
on rappelle les dates pour cette fin de
festival plein d'eau sur les vingt ans
pour rappel les dates vendredi 15
janvier à 20h30 parce que tu as toi qu'à
ça et samedi 16 le spectacle qui m'ont
tous et un final avec plein plein plein
de guest plein d'invités survivre ici à
la mjc du chemin vert merci d'être venus